hey this is pressure Locker a standard
dice has the numbers 1 to 6
each appearing with the probability of
1/6 if the dice is modified so the
number 6 appears with half the frequency
of the other numbers what is the new
probability of rolling a 6 I want to
mention I came across this problem in a
new book power up by Matthew Lane the
book uses video games to discuss really
interesting mathematical concepts and I
learned quite a few new things I did
receive a free advanced copy of the book
for review and it's really a great book
you should check it out there's a link
in the video description so returning to
the problem can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
in a standard dice the probability of
rolling the six is equal to 1/6 which is
the same as rolling any other number in
this loaded dice we want the probability
of six equal 1/2 the probability of
rolling any other number so one way you
might think about solving the problem is
that you might simply decrease the
probability in half that is you would
say the probability of rolling a six
will be 1/2 times 1/6 which equals 1/12
but there's a problem when you do this
if you add up all the other sides which
still have a probability of 1/6 then the
total probability will be too small it
will not add up to 1 you will actually
get that the probability of these
numbers will be equal to 11 over 12 so
this is the wrong answer because we need
the sum of all the probabilities to be
equal to 1
but no worries there's a way to fix this
since we need the probability to be 1 we
can scale each term by 12 over 11
this is so that we have 11 over 12 being
equal to one
once we scale it and if we scale all the
other terms by the same factor
we'll get the correct probability so 12
over 11 times 1 over 12 is equal to 1
over 11 and 12 over 11 times 1 over 6 is
equal to 2 over 11 and when we sum these
new probabilities we do in fact get that
the total probability is equal to 1 so
this is the correct answer the
probability of rolling six will be equal
to one over eleven but the lesson here
is that you can't simply adjust one
probability if you decrease the
probability of rolling a six you have to
compensate by adjusting all the other
probabilities there's another way you
could have come up with this answer
let's suppose P is equal to the
probability of rolling a six we then
have the probability of rolling any
other number will be equal to two P now
we need the total probability of all the
rolls to be equal to 1 so we can
algebraically add up these variables we
have one term of P and five terms of 2p
to be equal to 1 this will be a total of
11 P that's equal to 1 which means P is
equal to 1 over 11 so we get to the same
answer but it was done in an algebraic
way rather than scaling up the
probabilities and adjusting there's
another way you could have solved this
problem you could have also thought
about the odds of the rolls or the
relative probabilities so the odds of
rolling a six will be two to one against
rolling a six it'll be twice as likely
to roll any other number than rolling
the six now in order to convert these
odds
into probabilities what we do is we add
up all of these numbers we have one for
the six and we have five terms of two
this will be equal to 11 in order to
convert these odds into probabilities we
divide each of the relative odds by 11
so we then get to the same answer that
the probability of rolling a six is
equal to one divided by 11
did you figure out this problem and
which method did you use thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions that you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch around social media at pressure
Walker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description